hello would welcome to this video
playing tommasi Dark Passenger so still
it's anonymous okay I'm playing the set
up here which served me quite well in
recent games delaying also the night
development castles h5 has an important
point in white should not cancel him
well that's a good idea White has a
couple of useful moves they can play
instead but what actually do I play ok
maybe maybe defies the good idea now mmm
and it should be six because f4 it's
interesting
who very unconventional position now
just develop him i was thinking i have
25 here or not if I was hanging somehow
takes things things there is a form it's
a very complicated position I have nine
before here hmm ok I cannot calculate
this but it's too interesting to not to
play and if I tried to calculate it i
will take too long so here i have he
wants to just go d 4 years him I see a
CSC so night if five he wants to go
deform ok I'm takes takes takes a little
bit of an issue here with the Sigma
center
yeah it's very dangerous he has got a
huge pond center here like but he has
weaknesses it's not like it's all glory
you cannot cancel short as age 3 is
hanging and III g3 there are a couple of
weaknesses in this position so it's not
totally clear to me maybe why this
clearly better that this smooth hmm okay
here i can regroup definitely okay let's
start with it we should be 87 and start
with the recouping this bishop on b2
exam is a problem PCM bishops in general
here are limited value so I can what is
he doing and going for long castles
maybe okay that that I cannot prevent
but let's do this first
Bishop won't be too makes a strange
impression night a four is a threat but
the night on b6 ultimately will be
misplaced I think my dark squares are
weak but I'm not sure how relevant it is
my main idea i am and i think this is
completely out of play I will go Bishop
f5 and Bishop reform this is stadium
okay okay so probably I shouldn't have
gone to c7 putting everything in that
diagonal
yeah I still don't see a threat I'm
sorry what's what's happening here
this is the threat okay
hmm I didn't see that idea
and i miss played that at the beginning
like seven MOS ago it was a
strategically almost winning position
from like I think it was very good for
black but now hmm now I lost too much
time here didn't seeing this Bishop a5
maneuver this is now getting very
critical for me he quite clearly has a
couple of attacking pieces here
funny you move so 97 text ex-queen b6
and Bishop a 6am it's clearly extremely
dangerous night a4 I might have be five
that could save me as a little trick I'd
really could save me here time morning
my god now he wants to play like a
genius might work okay my ticket will be
six check check check check check and ok
anyway I'll go here check
as Bishop the aid anyway I have to play
down I know my queen is just saying I
didn't see that at all oh my god nah him
so he has been booze landing resins and
it was totally irritating i probably can
just take it no I cannot now i think the
real the real thing in this game is
starting here in this position here why
they strategically completely outplayed
because he has a dead Bishop b2 I have a
square on e4 and the only thing he can
play for is what happened and I don't
think it has to happen yeah maybe I'm
seeing it wrong if he gets the bishop to
a 5 but I cannot believe this this kind
of play it must it must be good I mean
okay maybe maybe you can argue i should
take with the night this this is so this
is something that you can you can
definitely argue why can cancel short
maybe this is also or something but i
wanted to have three pieces to control
affine i still don't believe this one
bit but maybe this is the thing i have
to go to see three I to c7 I mean and
then Bishop c3 is an issue
it's possible I mean I was very
optimistic here because if i get to any
endgame I'm winning this almost
automatically because i geti four and he
has a dead bishop won't be too the night
also is misplaced other day other than
mating me I mean he can try and use it
for mating attack but this has never
never forced a thing but it's a bit
difficult by concrete means definitely i
mean if i go here he put something on
the e-file this is wrong so i have to go
here and then he has this stuff it's
possible it's really possible that this
isn't so bad other thought as he gets to
a five and then it at least gets tricky
here the engine wants to do this which
is possible changing the structure
activating this but ok em i have to go
out here I still don't believe in it for
what I'm sorry the engine gives that
equal but if I'm not getting checkmated
those two pieces are completely useless
and I get defy if I have a pawn how CUDA
wants to do this and oops says equal
which I understand its kind of fits of
repetition five yeah and now it gets it
gets tricky definitely he does I did not
I didn't want to do that because um my
plan was always to take with this but
then there's f5 and here yeah it's
definitely
tricky I mean without any doubt yeah
that's a funny move okay I took it and
i'll be sure basics that's nice I mean
that's nice but take with the king there
is 97 threatening made and attacking the
Queen and now again 97 ever take it
check check check and I cannot stop the
checkmate yeah so I'm losing here this
jet is this until resigned okay i just i
mean actually okay I'm lost here and not
debating this but I could have continued
at least a little bit I've got a pretty
decent night and the rook here it's plus
3 but okay I didn't even see that it
wasn't like totally lost I mean like
Queen down now I was also a bit too
shocked by this turn of events because I
really thought that at this moment here
on white has strategically a huge issues
but ok he gets the SS it has this stuff
and he has the bishop to a 5 this is
something that I really didn't see
during the game and this makes the whole
thing a lot more interesting
so what does that mean actually at the
end I have to play differently here this
is probably just uh just the thing i
have to keep the the dark squares under
better control I can do this young it
takes each file the same thing just take
with the other piece and this could be a
big difference if we now assume you
would cancel long for the same thing I
go Bishop here is actually going astray
for him for tech decks computer just
wants to cancel and says I'm better but
account a castle short but I'm slightly
afraid doing that edgy for is a very
cool I mean I I cannot take yet this
gets gets me into trouble he threatens
this and Maru king so it's a little bit
of a problem so what does it mean I have
to be more precise I have to start with
this move probably and let's say castles
now I canceled long
I can take you six still don't I still
have not really understood the position
because I can absolutely not accept that
I shouldn't have at least a slightly
better position with the whole only four
hand and everything that deserve really
hard for me to accept this this one h 5
cancels long as he wants to take engine
once the castle short and then I really
I really feel like this is dangerous
maybe I'm just too scared yeah probably
i have to do it
yeah okay g4 it's not really happening
here I mean he can try to open and open
the file that same but it takes a while
and then those pieces they they don't do
anything yeah that probably doesn't work
I can of course try to prepare it like
this maybe the engine is totally cool
about stuff like that but I feel still
feel that this is dangerous for me now
I'm not made it I'm just winning this
but i might get made
hmm that's a really really interesting
position I'm sorry for looking at this
too long maybe because it's I very much
based my evaluations which are often
very clear I mean I just tend to endure
in the games be very frank what I think
I base this on those two pieces and they
are really really bad yeah this Bishop
is looking at its own porn and the night
is also not doing all that much while
those two pieces and they they they
compete 44 and they will ultimately use
that square that Bishop okay is
currently here but if it's on c7 is also
relatively decent piece um so I see
absolutely no reason why black shouldn't
be a little bit better so it's still
kind of amazing to me that I cannot
really prove it I mean the engine gives
me an advantage here yeah but I'm not
convinced myself engine says minus 0.6
but I'm still not so convinced because
g4 could be tricky and those kind of
ideas of something that the computer
currently are not currently still
sometimes miss evaluate salad and they
are also talking about a blitz game and
even objectively speaking and let's get
rid of the paint him very tricky very
tricky I mean the way it was happening
in the game I definitely evaluated this
this is wrongly I mean this is this is
this is okay for white based on the dark
squares i don't think i'm vers but it's
definitely it's definitely not a clear
cut thing and he played this very very
strong fashion with the Queen up and so
on yeah this is rookie five was also
funny and it's it's probably a
completely okay I mean it is hard for me
not to take this is kind of clear and
then he has those those things yes doc
fish find something here Knight c3 and
who is going to play that that seems to
draw yeah anyway that was a very nicely
played
and I didn't see how dangerous said that
will become in the game okay well I
throws a very long video thanks for
watching